the best business show research team
outsourced research to i believe cnbc
they found a 12 year old coder who's set
to earn 400 000 after selling nfts for
two months
12 years old this kid is richer than you
listening to this right now
this nerd who by the way nerd is a good
thing this kid literally his name is
benjamin
benjamin ahmed a 12 year old coder with
a successful nft collection that has
made over 350 000 to date and by the end
of august project's total earnings will
be over 400k some of you at home can't
pay your credit card or keep a budget
this kid's got projections for his nft
collection so take that out and get
ready for the rest of your friday his
first nft collection which he launched
this summer consists of 40 colorful
pixeled avatars the second collection is
called weird whales what a great name
which features 3 350 pixelated whales
each with distinct traits the second
project cost 300 bucks to make
the kid booked 350 000 in profit
which many consist of paying gas fees
which are charged to blockchains to
verify each nft and after posting a
twitter thread his entire collection
sold out nine hours he made 80 ether in
one day and 30 ether from the resale
market he rents a two and a half percent
royalty on each secondary sale when
asked what he was going to do with the
money ahmed doesn't have a bank account
and plans to keep the ether and not
convert it to fiat money however he may
get a bank account soon for tax purposes
12 year old kid ain't got no bank
account but makes more money than your
parents make pretty good he started
programming at five years old genius uh
at five years old i don't even think
that we could walk talk and eat all at
the same time this kid's coding uh he's
got two quotes here he says quote i
first learned about nfts earlier this
year i got fascinated with nfts because
you can easily transfer the ownership of
an nft by the blockchain
again just he just looks smart like it
looks like he should be in mit at 12.
next quote i plan to keep all of my
ether not converted to fiat money it
might be early proof that in the future
maybe everyone doesn't need a bank
account and just has an ether address
and a wallet and then can we pull up
he's got his account we've got his uh um
open suit yeah but bononi is the name
that he goes by here he said in school
year seven hobbies on swimming taekwondo
and coding have a look at my socials
in school have a look at my socials and
what a gangster in school year seven
yeah seventh grade you're in this you're
in the sixth or seventh grade yeah yeah
he's at seventh grade he's like year
seventh grade he said he's money than
you this year and he then he's flexing
on open c with his glasses half down
trying to steal your girl he said look
at that photo
like you're seven he's ready to rock
he's like yeah you're seven in the
league
bro what he's like it's not 12th year
doing this doing what life yeah
like what you mean seventh grade
dude what a game
you're you're 15 years old
kid
oh man we gotta get this kid on the show
this kid is this kid is literally what
every seventh grader should be trying to
do and then we got a picture of one of
them he's like balling out at the
cafeteria at lunch
he said i got two gatorades
what you want you want something russell
now he's probably charged in the kitchen
you want to go in the cafeteria you
gotta use my nfc
by the way i got two and a half percent
royalty on the resale
uh and then we got one of his weird
whales which by the way great name uh a
little purple background look look at
this thing this give me four hundred
thousand dollars selling seventh graders
this [ __ ] right here like literally that
is powering their parents money
the title should have read 12th grade uh
12 year old steals friends parents money
like that's how he made the money now
he's selling it on an open seat all
seriousness this is really cool because
it shows three things right one is uh at
the age of 12 being able to learn uh
programming at a very young age and then
learning how to apply it incredible we
should definitely teach more kids how to
do that uh two is he obviously
understands uh not only technology and
building but he also understands like
the social element of this he
understands kind of um the psychological
element of it he's talking about things
like um you know being able to uh uh
sell them um and have uh what was the
first one 40
avatars right so i only created 40 there
was scarcity to it the way that he put
it out there was pretty interesting he
had a twitter thread like this isn't
just oh i got lucky right he obviously
had a plan he was able to do that what i
love about it was the first collection
was only 40. the second collection had 3
350 pixelated whales it seems to me like
he was like all right i sold 40. well
that went pretty quick you know what we
should do let's create thousands of
those right and then the second
collection had 3
350 of them uh and then the kid i mean
he what is it 80 ether in one day and 30
already in the resale market kids made
110 ether uh and he this is all recent
so if he continues to get the two and a
half percent royalty he's gonna
literally just have passive income from
this project uh which is pretty
incredible and so the third thing is
he's like i'm not going back into the
fiat world i'm not taking it into a bank
account i'm gonna literally continue to
hold the digital assets uh and do that
in a way where i think this is the
future i mean
i feel like we should be celebrating
these types of kids who are obviously
incredibly smart right two is uh he's
making being a nerd cool right like
there's so many kids who they want to be
great at sports they want to be a
musician they want to be an actor
whatever we need more young kids that we
can point to and be like dude
this kid's rich
he literally is rich compared to your
parents
and he's 12. imagine what this kid does
when he's 18 20 30 40 years old he's
gonna be probably uh one of the richest
people in the world if he continues on
this path 400k at a 12 year old is
incredible i just looked up what uh
you're learning in seventh grade to
refresh my memory here
he's learning negative numbers fractions
decimals and
in percentages class you got to believe
this kid's like just sleeping
i mean do you go to school if you're 12
and you're learning fractions and
negatives
bro think about this for a second no
disrespect at all to teachers teachers
are important we love teachers the 12
year old made eight times the average
salary of a teacher in two months on the
internet and then he's got to sit there
and teachers like okay one over two is
equal to 15 percent they're starting
school up right now they're like oh how
was your summer he's like let me tell
you
i'm glad you asked show and tell i got
this whale there
you think he you think he tips the
t-shirt out there you appreciate the
lesson today
here's a 20 grab yourself lunch
i didn't want any of that appreciated
currency anyways like yeah principal's
like hey man let's see i know you're
only 12 and in seventh grade you can't
be tipping the teachers and passing out
cash or he's probably like you want to
do a donation to the school
is that the ultimate flex if you're 12
and you donate to the school and you
make them rename the hallway after you
that'll be all the time like imagine if
he goes imagine he goes to principal yo
prince listen i gotta i got a [ __ ]
idea let me tell you about this great
idea i have here's what we're gonna do
i'm gonna give you five thousand dollars
you're gonna name this oh man you're
gonna name it the ahmed gateway to to
heaven or something like that on that
cafeteria he's like what are you doing
they tried to give him a job he's like
check the name on the door
he goes by the way i'll give you another
5k if i can name the principal's office
op-ed's office
we're going to see you namaste you mean
my office
hey listen by the way i just give you
20. can't i just be the principal
yeah he's paying off all the teachers
i mean like yeah somebody said this kid
is like college professor rich already
college professor this kid's making more
money than some people who manage crypto
funds in the crypto industry are this
guy said in seventh grade i was throwing
fart bombs and playing grand theft auto
[Laughter]
i'm not gonna put him on blast you wanna
know i remember uh not seventh grade
it's probably like ninth grade uh
somebody that you guys know who's a
friend of mine uh he used to have the um
uh the stink bombs and he would always
go to uh the seniors uh locker area and
he would throw him home
before those things smell terrible right
before the period ended and then he
would leave and people was like man what
the hell is that smell eventually got
caught
and then just caught him a bunch of
these stink bombs and i was like that's
the stuff that we were doing in high
school this 12 year old is literally
you're playing on the computer making
400 thousand dollars this is the new
generation though it's a generational
ship i think it's pretty interesting he
realized he was like look this could be
the future of you not even needing a
bank account and just having a bitcoin
or ether crypto wallet in general um and
then i love the fact that he's making
money on the resale he's right
two and a half percent is actually
pretty reasonable that's not crazy we've
seen well as high as 20 30 but in all
seriousness i do think it speaks volumes
that he's in seventh grade and he
clearly understands this stuff much
better and quicker than people that are
in their 30s 40s 50s 60s 70s etc right
like people who have been around for a
much longer time who have used the
internet for a much longer period of
time have been much more educated and
have resources to develop their
knowledge on these topics he's clearly
got it more than they do right not only
does he understand what it is and how to
do it and all this stuff but he's out
there doing it he's making money on it
he's trading him he's got a collection
all this stuff he understands the
nuances of crypto and ethan all this
stuff so i think it speaks volumes that
someone of that age is able to quickly
figure it out based on his kind of uh
the how he grew up with the internet
right i think that goes that's uh not
spoken about enough is like people that
grow up with the internet understand
this stuff much much much better than
people who didn't and i think uh he's
the perfect example of that
what's up guys bang bang your boy pomp
thanks so much for watching the best
business show our goal is to make this
the largest most actionable business
show in the world and to do that we need
your help we've partnered with sofi as
our exclusive sponsor because they have
a piece of software that we think will
help you take the information that we
share on a daily basis and make it
actionable we want every single person
to pursue and achieve financial security
and financial freedom in order to do
that you gotta act and sofi allows you
to do it so you can go to sofi.com pomp
today you can open up an account and
when you open up an account you can
invest in all sorts of different types
of assets etfs individual stocks ipos
bitcoin cryptocurrencies they even have
an automated investing function if you
want to invest sofi can help you they've
got a couple of different offers that
you can benefit from the first open an
invest account and they'll give you up
to a thousand bucks for free kind of a
no-brainer second is if you go on and
you buy one of the cryptocurrencies that
they offer they'll go ahead and they'll
give you ten dollars of bitcoin for free
and third some of you are saying i
already have a brokerage account i
already have an account somewhere else
right now you can get up to five
thousand dollars for transferring your
account that's right sofi doesn't care
where your current account is but if you
transfer from that place to sofi they'll
pay you up to five thousand dollars for
doing it why wouldn't you do it it's up
to five thousand dollars for free head
on over to sofi.com today to get started
and come back tomorrow and watch more of
the best business show together we're
going to build the biggest show in the
world
[Music]